- We accidentally are lesbian content,
but I never think of us as,
"Let's make something
the lesbians will like."
- Yeah, I don't think
about makin' anything
that anybody will like.
(Blonde Women giggle)
- We know.
Hi, I'm Trixie Mattel.
- And I'm Katya.
- And we are two queens who like to watch.
- Truer words could not have been spoken.
- And today, we're
watching "The Ultimatum."
It's a Netflix original
program about dating and love,
but there's a twist.
- ♪ They're queer, baby! ♪
- We have discovered a bevy of lesbians
who, in a dramatic turn of events,
are not both rushing to the altar.
(upbeat jazzy music)
- Honey, listen, this is a show
that is so chock-full of suspense.
There's gonna be spoilers at every turn.
So why don't you go ahead
and watch the whole season.
Come back to us later.
- So basically, these are
couples who, um, you know,
one of 'em wants to get married,
the other one's on the fence,
and they're entering the ultimatum arena
to mingle with other
couples, and figure out,
"Am I really with the one
or when I'm surrounded by other people,
am I tempted by the fruit of another?"
So let's get a lay of the
land here at "The Ultimatum."
- [Katya] Okay. - [Trixie]
Now, it's always been straight
couples, but this is all lesbians.
- I wanna get married to this person.
I wanna bring children-
- [Trixie] 24 years old,
"I wanna get married."
People are obsessed with
getting married young.
- My parents got married at 22 and 24.
- Geez.
- I deserve to be married.
That's why I'm issuing an ultimatum.
- Old tomatoes are horrible.
- Now new tomatoes.
- Fresh.
- See, I am noticing a
butch/femme dichotomy
in most of these couples.
- Hello, everyone.
- [Katya] Oh, I love that
dress, very Amy Adams. Kinda.
- Mary, she looks like
she's going to a toga party.
- Stop. Green satin.
- [Vanessa] Is it correct
that you're not queer?
- I am not.
- "Oh, so you're not queer?"
"I'm not."
And what if they all walked out?
- Yeah, be like, "(beep) you, bitch."
- Very happy you're here.
- Sam and Aussie, they were like,
- [Blonde Women in unison] "Awwwww."
- "You're not queer, that's, that's okay."
They were like disappointed
but supportive.
I don't care if people are queer.
I talk a big game, but I think
straight people are fun too.
(Katya titters)
They don't deserve rights.
- [Katya] No.
- By a show of hands,
who in the relationship
issued the ultimatum?
- What's funny is I'm on TV all the time,
and, but opening up my
personal relationship
for the world to talk about and watch.
- To dissect, analyze,
and then give feedback on?
- I could never.
- I feel like I found my person.
- You know I hate that.
- I know, I know you do.
- You know I hate "my person." - I do too.
- I hate it too. It's whimsical.
- But, "my person?"
- "My person" is like. - (Trixie gags)
- "My person" is "live, laugh, love."
- Phrases I would love to strike
from the English language,
"speaking my truth" and "my journey."
- Girl, my other one is,
"at the end of the day-"
- "At the end of the day-"
- It's the night.
- During the nighttime.
At the end of the day,
my journey is about speaking my truth.
- At the end of the day, it is what it is.
I am who I am.
- Yeah. And
whatever the case may be,
to be honest, it's just-
- Tea. - You know it's
my journey.
- It's tea.
- Yeah, and that's my person.
- And that's my person.
- And along the way, you'll see a future,
and maybe even fall in
love with someone new.
- Fall in love with someone new.
- This is very lez. Lipsticks and diesels.
- As a new couple in a trial marriage,
and then you'll do the-
- What in the hell is goin' on?
- They basically make them play
house in a new relationship
to make them think, "Well,
what about the one you're in?"
The only way to make you
appreciate what you have
is to show you what else is out there.
They all seem so happy.
I'm like, "Y'alls (beep)
is about to hit the fan.
You know that right?"
- [Katya] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Do you think ultimatums are okay?
- I think it's threatening. And I
think it's confrontational.
- That's why I don't like it.
- It's saying, "If you don't
do what I want, I'm leaving."
- It's a combat-tave, a combative.
How do you say that word?
It's like. - Horny.
- Horny.
- You meant horny.
If I get even a whiff of an ultimatum,
mama, you see like smoke and I have like
- 100% - "Wile E. Coyote,"
like scrammed out of the picture.
- So the couples are now single,
and at the end of the week,
they have to pick someone
who's not their partner
to undergo a trial marriage with.
Are lesbians open the way gays are open?
No, right? Gay men?
- I mean, I don't think women
like ass up on Sniffies,
getting loads.
- Right.
- Now, answer me this question.
Why am I gay but she's a
lesbian? What's that all about?
Oh, like we should just all be gay?
- It sounds like a different
species is what I'm trying
to say.
- Really, last night, I fell
asleep next to a person-
- Joe, whoa!
Lexi.
Lexi said, you said these are lesbians?
Okay. Said lesbians, alright?
(Crew laughs)
Now, which pool should we go to?
Oh, this one? Oh.
(Trixie preens)
Lexi is like, "Listen,
I'm testin' the waters."
- Getting used to this idea
of calling someone our exes.
- I love breasts, by the way.
- Yeah. I love everyone's bodies.
- Like sexually.
- Oh you do?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Just lettin' you know.
(Trixie fizzles)
- Did you like when I
took my top off just now?
- Well, I noticed you
didn't have any breasts
so that was hard for me. - Mmmmmm.
- You're the most masculine
person I've ever been
out on a date with. - Fair.
- In the wild, I don't see a lot of,
like top butch women
dating each other- -Hmmhmm.
- and we're seeing that
now, which is good.
People should keep their options open.
- The "boyfriend twin" thing
is a strange phenomenon.
- What about drag queens
who date drag queens? - No.
No. No. - When I was single, I'd be like,
"Guys don't wanna date me
'cause I'm a drag queen."
And people would be like,
"Would you date a drag queen?"
I'm like, "Are you (beep) disgusting?"
- I'd rather have you steal my furniture
than put mascara on.
(Blonde Women chortle)
I'd rather have you,
you have a hardcore
crack cocaine addiction.
If I catch you with panty hose,
the FBI is getting involved.
(Blonde Women cackle and snort)
- I don't date masc.
- Yeah.
- But I'm also like.
- I like these butch bitches
goin' out on dates together.
- I do too. - It's a funny energy.
- It's a great energy.
- It's funny.
Two dads watchin' the
kids swim in the pool.
- Two dads who have no interest
in rubbing their cock heads together.
- Do you have a preference
to like masculine
or feminine men?
- I thought I did for quite a while.
Absolutely, I don't.
- I don't care either.
- No.
- I can't get down with
a girl that flat up like,
eats like a juicy raw fuckin' steak.
- I find this fascinating.
- I think that's really weird.
- Do you think it's unreasonable?
- Yes.
- You do? Yes.
- I'm a vegetarian.
- Yeah.
- I never ask anyone to eat differently
because I hate being asked
about my eating preferences.
- And also, being a vegetarian
is not an all or nothing
proposition.
Oh, you have a piece of meat,
and all of a sudden, your
vegetarianism is over.
- It's over. - No.
- They take your chip
away. - Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They take, it's not a relapse.
- No.
It's like, it's so bizarre.
'Cause when somebody eats a
meal without meat, I'm not like,
"I thought you ate meat?
Well, where is it?"
Like, I'm not like that.
But if I have something with
meat in it, people are like,
"Hmm, well, hmm." It's so
(beep) I don't know what it is.
- It's so crazy. It is crazy.
- So they're gonna have a little party
where they talk about dating each other,
and they're gonna talk
about how small of a dating pool it is
to be lesbian even in the bigger cities.
I'm just thinkin' enjoy this
camaraderie while it lasts-
- Because it is all going downhill, bitch.
- 'Cause the second you
start dating each other's
girlfriends- - Mama.
- It's gonna be (beep) Pamplona.
- Guys be willing to tell everyone else
who your number one was?
- [Couples] No. No.
- Girl, you're not the host.
- Hostility, sarcasm, jealousy,
I feel like, me being
born and bred in Jersey,
I've got that in me.
(Katya chuckles)
I think it would be
best if this experience
just became like a polyamorous orgy.
- Girl, I don't know.
- A show about ultimatums for marriage,
and you just want it to be an orgy?
- [Aussie] It's a small world out there.
- (Australian accent) It's
a small will out there.
- (Australian accent) I naur.
- In Milwaukee, I do
feel like I know a lot
of the gay people.
- Yeah.
- But LA is joggin'.
- Yeah, but we still know them all.
- I can't believe you're wearing jewelry,
and you're like playing with
your hair, and I'm into you.
- She is team too much.
Oh, she's kind of
usually into butch girls.
Well, this is what's weird,
saying that you are into femme men
or masc men or anything
is very not cool to say.
But in lesbian world, I
think it is more okay to say,
"I really only like
butch girls." - Hmmhmm.
- "I really only like
femme girls." -Hmmhmm.
- Their butch/masc correlates
better to top/bottom,
I would say.
You know what I mean?
It's more about a role rather
than like a personality type
'cause I know a lot of femme tops.
- Blouses.
- Yeah, blouses.
Okay, so Mildred and Aussie,
who's from Australia,
if you didn't catch that, are
thinking about partnering up.
- Identify as male, female. You know what
does that look like?
- I think that's healthy.
She's open to discovering
things about herself
but she's not pressuring
herself to immediately answer.
- Yeah.
- You know?
- Mm-hmm.
- [Trixie] Vanessa and Lexi are on a date,
and maybe it does not go well.
- It's hard for me to
imagine marrying anyone.
- Mama, if you don't like
sniffin' for truffles,
why are you crawling around in the forest?
- I don't know.
- What is she doin'?
- Do you feel like there
was like an actual chance
that Xander could find someone else?
- Um. No. I'm beautiful.
- Work. Love her.
- Xander has been saying
she might be asexual,
and that I'm the only one that
she could have feelings with.
- Asexual doesn't mean you
don't want to be with anyone.
- [Katya] Yes.
- What exactly did you
think you were gonna get
out of this process if there
was no chance for Xander
to be with other people?
What the fuck did you come here for?
- Lexi's comin' hard.
- She's comin' hard with the truth bomb.
- Thank you.
Xander owes Lexi a fruit basket for this.
- Yes, absolutely.
- I think I don't understand.
Why is that upsetting you?
- 'Cause you're not risking anything!
- Yeah.
- You didn't think she could
be attracted to anyone else.
Somebody should tell
you where the door is.
This, this isn't for you.
It's a lie world. Vanessa's a fake person.
- Lexi is being so real.
- This is like a breath of fresh air.
- It's very refreshing.
- Yeah. And you know what?
Lexi's also looking out
for the other women here.
- Yeah, yeah.
She's trying to preserve like
the integrity of the space.
- I will never have to
look that girl in the face,
but somebody else will have
to for the next three weeks,
likely my ex-girlfriend,
and I'm angry about that.
(Katya snaps)
- This is sickening.
Now, this is First Kill, honey!
- Yeah. (rasps and claps)
- This is the lesbian drama I wanted.
How would you do on a show like this?
- Horribly.
Dating? Are you (beep) kidding me?
- Yeah.
- If they have a like competition
for "Mr. Burns" impersonators, then maybe.
- Now, the chickens are
coming home to roost, honey.
- Cluck-cluck, bitch.
- Vanessa starts like hitting
on my ex in front of me.
- By the way, that's
the point of the show,
so that's invalid.
- Yeah.
- Also, I'd hit on Mal too.
- There's a sleazy,
and there's a skillful way to be flirting.
- What's the slutty way to flirt?
- Sleazy way, it is like-
- A lot of perfume?
That thing where you draw
on your nostrils bigger?
(Katya wheezes)
- Larger nostril illusion.
- Larger nostrils is super flirty.
- [Katya] Super flirty, yeah, yeah.
- You walk up here just like.
- Yep.
- I think the only acceptable
way is to pretty much do
everything a friend might do,
like laugh at their jokes.
- Yeah.
- Ask questions.
- Be a nice person.
- But you know what the ultimate thing is?
- What?
- This happens a lot.
If you're in anywhere where
there's even a remote amount
of noise and you go to talk,
and someone goes, "What?"
And they lean in and like
put a hand on you to listen,
I'm like, "I'm yelling,
and it's quiet in here."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't do all that,
especially when they grab your testicles
and grip 'em real hard and
say, "What did you say?"
- Exactly. - And then they lick your ear.
- Right. And then they pull
away and they're in their hands.
And I have to go get them sewn on again,
another trip to Istanbul?
- And then before you get on the flight,
you got to paint those nostrils back in.
- And then I'm having
to fly internationally
with coke again.
(Katya tee-hees)
Like another balloon?
"Maria Full of Grace," again?
I got a balloon full of coke up my ass,
no balls, and huge nostrils.
(Blonde Women guffaw)
- I don't even know who you've
been going on dates with.
- I think you're gonna
be like pretty surprised,
but like, is Yoly.
- [Vanessa] Yeah. Please, explain that.
- [Xander] Yeah.
- Xander's like afraid
to oppose her right now.
- Whatever.
- Baby.
- [Vanessa] No.
- Devastation.
- Diabolical.
- Be as selfish with her-
- They have 120 pound women
with these wine glasses
the size of a fish bowl.
- Drinking Triple Manhattans,
and like- (gurgles)
- Maybe you should be with this person
because she wants to get
married, because she-
- Half drunk trying to explain
this kind of complicated scenario.
"And she said, and I said,
that she didn't say that."
Even a good relationship where
you both are on the same page
would be tested by this. - Yeah.
After a week of dating,
the girls have to pick
a trial marriage wife.
- And then I also learned
what a power bottom was.
I don't if you know what power bottom is.
- I know what a power bottom is.
- Offended. Offended.
- I know what felching is, okay?
I know what felching
is. I know what it is.
- I know what a power
bottom is. I'm not an idiot.
I might be heterosexual
but I'm also a whore.
- Yeah. I, I do anal three times a week.
- I've dated someone like Rae, and-
- Who was that?
- Yes.
- What?
- [Vanessa] Who is this?
- It's a Bumble person.
- I've never heard about this ex.
- Funny, I don't have this in
my scrapbook of her love life.
Yeah. Hmm.
- I'm ready to see Vanessa
get a reality check.
- Might be like a full
pitchfork and mob scenario.
- Is this like tractor girl?
- Is this tractor girl?
- Is this that (beep) John Deere (beep)?
- Did you see- (claps)
- Can we ask you- - Yeah.
- And she did it again?
- That is so wild. Wow.
- She mouthed the words
(beep) off to her girlfriend.
- I, I choose Yoly because I think
that you and I had the
deepest conversations.
- And you hate the girl I'm
with, and so do I, so. - Hmmhmm.
- Because you don't have
anything to lose at this moment
because the world just
saw you for who you are.
- Gag-a-rino.
- You've been telling Xander
to fuck off all night,
and it's hurting all of us,
everyone sitting at this
table except for you.
- She is getting-
- Evisceration.
- A hot dose of, like a
reality check up her ass.
- Listen, this process is
supposed to teach them something
about themselves, and
she is getting learned.
- She is learning.
She's gonna get PhD in self-knowledge.
Xander's lucky to be surrounded by women
who barely know her and
are looking out for her.
- And there's something
about Vanessa that like,
kind of fits that.
- I like pit vipers.
- Vanessa, you better pick
the only one at the table
who likes you.
- Mary.
- You would be an amazing wife.
- Her ex is like eye-rolling.
God, standing up in front
of your current girlfriend.
- It's (beep) diabolical.
- I couldn't. I couldn't,
I wouldn't want to.
If I was her,
and my partner and this
other girl were having
this connection, I'd be like (mutters).
Or this.
- Yeah.
- David would go, "Let
me just say something.
This person cross dresses.
They don't know how to fold laundry.
And in the morning, they
have terrible breath."
- Yeah, horrible driver.
- Have fun.
- I choose Lexi.
- I'm sayin' it-
- They're (beep) hot together.
- Lexi and Mal-
- They're (beep) sexy.
- Yeah, very sexy.
- What I want and who I want, it's my ex.
- What?
- She chose her ex.
- Wrong queen, mama.
She can't do that-
- You're not allowed to do that, Mary.
It's like when BenDeLaCreme
eliminated herself
on "Drag Race."
It was against the rules but it was real.
- I'm so, so in love with Mildred.
- This is already like the most
authentic dating style show
we've watched.
- With intensity, yeah.
- This feels a lot more nuanced.
- Because it's women!
- It's women and I'm very invested
in what's gonna happen to these people.
- Yeah.
Tiff comes back and
she decides to go along
with the trial marriage.
- It's very hard to open
up, and I apologize to you.
- The butch girls, don't get it twisted,
they're the most sensitive of everyone.
They might be tough on the
outside, but these bitches,
they feel (beep).
- [Joanna] Watching someone
you love talk about forming a
relationship with somebody
else, it's uncomfortable.
- No (beep).
Thank you, Dr. Einstein.
- Revelations.
- [Joanna] Or you'll leave here alone.
- Vanessa is living.
- Vanessa is diabolical.
- She's happy.
- She's diabolical.
- She's vibing.
- [Vanessa] I truly care about you.
- She didn't shake her hand.
She hates her.
She hates her, Mary.
- Well, I mean.
- It's almost like, shake her hand.
It's a pity, almost like.
Yeah, just throw the dog a bone.
- And I love you guys both,
and I hope we get to hang out.
- Oh she's like, "I hope
the (beep) we don't, bitch."
- I hope she trips on the stairs.
Rae's athletic enough
not to fall with her.
- I know. "I hope she
trips on the stairs!"
And complimenting the other one, yeah.
- That is-
- Rae will be fine.
- Yeah, Rae will be fine.
- [Trixie] You know, like any marriage,
you immediately get your nipples pierced.
- Yeah, like a true diva.
- Are you attracted to nipple piercings?
- I am not.
- I'm not either,
but I love like face tattoos and stuff.
- I do too.
- Hot.
- [Katya] I do too.
- ♪ Hot. Hot. ♪
- I also love neck tattoos.
- ♪ Hot. ♪
- If David ever left me,
my next boyfriend would look like an extra
from like a jail show.
(Vanessa whimpers)
- Oh God, I can't even.
- This is the hip replacement
of the lesbian world.
- She's a trooper. I don't know. That.
She didn't scream or anything.
- Come take a selfie with my nipples.
- She's gonna do OnlyFans.
- Oh, Lexi's gonna love that picture.
(Blonde Women snicker)
This was step one of
me redefining who I am.
- Get bangs.
By the way, Vanessa's trying
to like pump the brakes
and show everyone she's not crazy.
First thing she does is go
get her nipples pierced on TV.
Your breasts are gonna be untouchable
for two to three weeks now.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah.
I hooked up with someone who
had recently pierced nipples-
- Uh-huh. - it was a, it's a no-fly zone.
- When I was in high school,
I went with my friend, Rachel,
to get an industrial piercing. - Uh-huh.
- You know what that is?
- No.
- It's the bar that they
put through both parts
of your cartilage.
- Oh, okay.
- So it's like a bar.
So you did one, two?
And I stood there, and I was like 15.
She just got her license,
whatever, she had her mom's note.
We're sitting there and I'm watching.
Her eyes like flutter from pain,
and I immediately see blood running
down the tattoo person's,
you know, so much blood when
you're piercing cartilage.
And I remember being like,
"My best friend's a
(beep) psychopath." Like.
This is a crazy thing to do.
- Yeah. It was the first thing
I did when I went to college,
I got this pierced and this pierced.
- You had this?
- Yeah. I still have-
- Did it hurt so bad?
- No, but it was, there was a crunch
'cause they clamp it and then they go,
the needle goes through and
there was a crunching sound.
- Girl.
- 'Cause my parents wouldn't let me do it
when I was in high school.
- You look like a fly fishing accident
for the first two years
of college, or what?
- I was goth.
- Oh, that's fine.
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
- So Tiff and Sam get into a big fight
because Sam mentioned
she's never slept in a bed
with a dog before, which,
I mean, depending on the
breed and size of the dog,
you know, some would consider me a dog.
- I don't want anyone to be around my dog
that doesn't give a shit.
- Oh, come on.
Give me a break girl.
- I'm not, we're, mama, we're dating you.
- I am that nurturing,
loving person with animals.
- I find that very hard to believe.
- Oh come on, Mary.
- Oh Mama, get a grip.
- You're telling me you don't
have the emotional nuance
to understand that this person loves dogs
but doesn't wanna sleep with your dog?
- [Tiff] I'm asking you to act
like you care about my dog!
Like it's not that hard.
- Oh, no.
- Maybe it's 'cause we don't have dogs.
- No, no, no, no.
You need to get off the TV,
and go to the (beep) dog park, bitch.
- It's a different show.
- Hi, it's Trixie Mattel.
- And I'm Katya.
- And we are hosting "Date My Bitch,"
a show where lesbians get together
and date each other's dogs.
- Yeah, Golden Retrievers,
Siberian Huskies, Weimaraners.
- Greyhounds.
- Labradoodles.
- You'll see what happens
when they stop being nice,
and start getting real.
- We're not dating you.
We're dating your dog.
- You're gonna see what happens
when you date my dog sight unseen.
(Blonde Women caw and clap)
- Xander and Yoly have had a great start
to their trial marriage,
and they're about to start
having sexual intercourse.
- Ooh. Vanessa is not gonna like this.
- Oh shit I think,
I like, really, really,
really like Xander, and-
- See, this is where this experiment
gets actually dangerous.
This is gettin' really lez.
- [Yoly] You are so.
♪ Let's be friends and
maybe something more ♪
- You and I meet a lot of lesbian women
at our meet-and-greets.
- Yeah. I've also noticed
that you have no qualms
about asking, "Are you a lesbian?"
- They usually are.
- Many times they weren't.
- Sure. That one time they
were mother and daughter.
- It's been-
- But that doesn't mean they're not.
- That's true.
- They can still be
lesbians, not together.
Should I start asking if they're straight?
- No, because who cares
if they're straight.
- Right.
- You know.
- I'm still gonna ask if they're lesbian.
So this is the start of Fingergate.
And Vanessa and Rae are
gonna hook up a little bit,
which I did not see coming.
"The Ultimatum,"
they frame it like it's
about their relationship,
but it's really about-
- Piercin' nipples and finger blastin'.
- Yeah.
- Should we go to sleep?
- She is so beautiful,
and I think she does
have kind of a magnetism,
and so I think she could get people
to act against their own
interest a little bit.
- Absolutely.
- Kind of like....me.
- [Vanessa] Yes.
- You know what's so funny? Oh, wow.
- [Rae] Keep doing that. That felt good.
- How do they have sex if there's no man?
I can just feel straight
people watching this.
- Well, where do they put the dick?
- 'Cause they think
the insertive penis is-
- The end-all be-all of
sex. It's like, oh my god.
- 19 year old man might be like,
finger in the belly button and be like,
"I'm in!"
Belly button, microwave, under the bed.
Who knows? - Yeah.
- I kind of wanted us talk
about what happened last night.
- I had a lot of fun last
night. I believe I fingered you.
(Blonde Women clutch and cachinnate)
- I believe-
- Your honor, your honor.
- Your honor, I would
like to take the stand.
- Yeah.
- I believe I fingered that woman.
- In my defense, I do
believe I fingered her.
(Blonde Women hee-haw)
- I think that was it, right?
- [Katya] You also fisted me.
- I like texted with Lexi.
- Oh, Lexi (beep) hates her.
- She's gonna try to figure
out what her life is like-
- By the way, Rae's not the victim.
She participated in this.
- Of course. Yeah.
- She's just as guilty.
- Takes two to tango.
So we got a party goin' on
and the couples are talking to each other
about how their swaps have been going on.
- Be able to show up better to the table
when love and marriage is on the line.
- This personality type
is a lot to handle.
- Look at Aussie staring
into space, being like,
"Who are these bitches?
How did I get here?"
- I got my nipples pierced.
- That's horrible.
(Blonde Women rattle and caw)
- What the (beep)?
That's judgy.
- Yeah. I mean- - It's a little mean.
Lexi needs to get cool it a little bit,
I feel like.
- Lexi, you can hate her and
not blame her nipple piercings.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Even before Xander,
my ex-boyfriend loved the shit out of me.
- He like loved me until I (beep) myself.
- And then like he'd clean it up.
- And then, yeah, he put it in his mouth.
- I'm too lazy. Yeah.
- What is with the bullshit?
(Katya hisses)
- Love it. Love it.
- [Katya] All right. Lexi's
about to lay it down on Vanessa
about-
- Fierce!
- Fingergate!
- Hi, server. Can we get another mimosa?
Anyway, did you finger my girlfriend?
- Um, do you guys have finger
bowls here? Speaking of which.
- Taking things slow.
- She said, "Can I smell your finger?"
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I think I smell my
wife's pussy on your finger.
- Yeah, the dripping
pussy juice on your hand?
- I think you wore my
woman like a mood ring,
and we need to talk about it.
- Which is like not what happened.
Seems like the exact opposite.
(Blonde Women applaud)
- Yes.
- Gooped. - Oh, she's just scalped.
- Plucked.
- She's just on horseback
with a knife scalping.
- Plucked.
- Scalping.
I wish Vanessa would be like,
"Actually, she told me
I had the sweetest pussy
she ever tasted."
- Yeah. "And she ate it till the bone."
- Can we try to see
how we can overcome it?
- Aussie has a good attitude.
I would say it's a little misplaced.
- Yeah. It's a little Deepak Chopra,
and we're at the "Bad
Girls Club" right now.
- When she saw the
lingerie that was on you
when you got ready that night?
- Lexi is almost projecting
whatever she feels toward Rae
onto her.
- [Lexi] Fuck the sex. I don't
give a shit about the sex.
- Uh. Yeah, you do.
- Yes you do, Mary. What
are you talking about?
- My problem is with the
person Rae let inside of her.
- She's not the devil!
- I know. She's not
"Hannibal Lecter," bitch.
- No.
- She's "Clarice."
- So Aussie and Mildred
had a chill first couple
of weeks together, but
then they started fighting.
Aussie packs it up and
leaves the trial marriage.
- Ooooooh.
- [Katya] (Australian accent)
Oh naur. I got to gaur.
- Nice packer. I think
that's a good trait.
Is she leaving a note?
(beep)!
Sorry, bitch.
(Australian accent) I'm going haurme.
- [Katya] Xander and Yoly
are getting hot and heavy,
and they tell each other
that they love one another.
- Ah, why do people do this show?!
- Here I go tearing up.
- If you say you're tearing
up, but I don't see tears,
I'm mad.
- Mama, oh.
- Don't pat the tear. Better be real.
- The tears have to come down your cheeks
before you start wiping.
- Girl, at least we're not seeing Visine.
- Oh my God.
- We're not seeing eyedrops.
- It's diabolical.
- Andrew, where is he now?
- [Yoly] It's terrifying but I love you.
- Oh my God. (squalls)
I like really don't like that.
- Why?
- I just, everybody's (beep)
up their relationships for fun,
like for fun.
- For our fun.
- I love you.
- Aye yai yai.
Infatuation and love are
two different things.
- And that's where I
get a little conflicted
'cause I'm like, "Y'all need to grow up."
- As long as they realize
that "I love you" means
"I'm infatuated with you."
- [Trixie] Yeah, yeah.
- That's fine.
And then Mal and Lexi have
been getting along great
in their trial marriage,
but Lexi only wants Rae.
And Mal is becoming more set on Yoly
who is in love with Xander.
- Girl, it's the ultimate
you snooze, you lose.
(beep)!
- Mal is about to introduce Lexi to her
and Yoly's friend group.
- Girl. - This is so
weird. This is so strange.
- This is the craziest exercise in like,
"How do we (beep) up a good thing?"
- I'm introducing Lexi
to my entire circle.
- What?
- Her friend is like, "No,
y'all are brainwashed.
This is whack."
- Yeah, yeah.
"And what the (beep) is
that camera doin' there?"
All the couples besides Aussie and Mildred
are having their final night together
in their trial marriages.
- It's the final night
to slip that finger.
- And Xander and Yoly, in particular,
are having a hard time saying goodbye.
- Thank you for loving me the way you do.
- Ooh. These couples have
to go home and watch this.
Their parents are gonna watch it.
- Oh, I never even thought of that.
- They have to go watch it.
- Oh.
This is like hardcore intimacy.
- This is intimacy!
- Hardcore intimacy.
- Intimacy!
- Well, this is the stereotype
I get with lesbians,
the fast track to heavy, heavy-
- Heavy.
- Intimacy.
- Like intense emotional bonding.
♪ This is the moment ♪
- [Katya] It's gonna be a long-
- This "Greatest Showman"
music or some (bleep)-
- "The Greatest Showman"
like choppy waters
on the Finger Lakes tonight.
- But it's Netflix.
These songs should be like.
♪ Ooh, finger my pussy in my bedroom ♪
♪ Shove the Hitachi up my ass ♪
♪ Nipple clamps on my titties ♪
- All the couples come
together with their exes
and their person they wifed
up with to hash it all out.
- Vanessa and Rae, how
was living together?
- Rae is certainly not my
typical type of personality.
- I live for this bitch.
I live for her!
- I'll say this, she's messy,
but Vanessa's bringing and giving.
- She is.
- You know the producers are
in video village like this.
- Yes, yes, totally.
- They have a pentagon back there-
- Keep talking, keep talking.
with a, like a chicken bone like, oooooh.
- Do it again, Vanessa.
- Yes, Vanessa. - Yeah.
Ugh. Plucked.
Lexi's like, "Act a
fool, girl." - Plucked.
- We've really been working on ourselves.
- Sorry, working in
ourselves, in each other.
- Lexi's gonna be like, "Let's
talk about the fingering."
- Yeah. "So when did you blast
her pussy with your fingers,
you pit viper?"
- "How many press-ons did
you lose in my woman?"
- Please accept this apology
and know that regardless
of my views on marriage,
which, surprise, have
changed since I got here.
- Your apology is performative.
- [Katya] Yeah.
- You don't expect people to
just brush it under the rug
now that you said sorry.
- [Katya] Damn.
- Leave that little piece of
openness in your heart, every-
- one to like allow for there
to be growth here in general.
- Yeah. I think people are
dog-piling Vanessa a little,
like she's kind of showed her ass,
but she's trying to tell you
all that she's not perfect.
- Mal was like nothing but
supportive. She'd sage me.
- Sage me?
- Isn't that beyond fingering?
(Katya puffs)
- Xander has shown in the three weeks
that we've been together
that she can absolutely be that future.
- [Katya] Gag.
- Could that be your future?
(beep) hell.
That's, that's some wild (beep).
- I want what I want,
and I'm still trying to
figure out what I want.
- There you go.
- Okay. That's clear.
- She's explained it perfectly.
- Yeah, oh that makes
sense. Okay, now, I get it.
- We did talk about
romantically being involved.
Were you physically involved as well?
Cause we did speak to
what we'd physically-
- And that was your choice.
- She said, "No, I like
to play the victim."
I want the producers to roll out a TV
and show them fingering.
- Actually, Ellen.
- Actually, here's uh HD footage
of you guys scissoring in 4K.
- Yeah.
- Connection for me is very important.
- Is that answering the question?
- That's not answering the question.
- Mama, that's not answering the question.
Did you (beep) her or not?
- Did he (beep) her, Dolores?
- If you had the choice,
would you live with Yoly
for three more weeks?
- [Katya] Whoa.
- I feel like that's something
that you and I need to discuss alone.
- Oh, come on.
- Oh, that's (beep).
- If you wanna sit home and
journal, sit home and journal,
but you're on the old tomato.
- Yeah. You're bringing the
old tomato to the red table.
- I'd feel like a fool if I
were to enter into three weeks
with you, if you would
prefer it to not be with me.
- You know what, though?
Falling for someone new,
it's not struck by lightning,
it's not out of the sky.
You advanced it, you
invested it. - Yeah, yeah.
- You nurtured it.
- You pursued it actively.
-We didn't expect it.
- I could never do this.
Emotional racquetball.
- It is.
Mama, it's emotional like water polo.
It's one week until ultimatum day,
and they have a mixer with everybody.
Do a round of fake hugs.
- I want Mal to be my personal stylist.
- Yeah.
- Vanessa messaged me to let me know
that Xander and Yoly were communicating.
- I'm, I, this is, I'm, I like this.
- Yeah!
- Vanessa thinks that
she's a fire starter,
but like she feels more
of like a fruit fly, like-
- Girl, Vanessa won't be able
to go to the bank after this.
- I know.
- Hey, are you that messy lezzy?
- Oh, you're that bitch
from the tomato show.
- The message said, "I don't wanna see it
if it's not a selfie." Winky face. ;)
- Winky face?
- Winky.
- That's another finger.
That's the second knuckle.
Digital finger.
- I'm gonna go take a shot.
- [Katya] Oh God.
- Love it. Love it.
- I'm gonna go get blotto.
What could, what could possibly go wrong?
- When I wanna control my emotions,
I know that shots will help. - Yes!
- I know that.
- When I wanna de-escalate
a situation-  - Shots.
- I turn to liquor.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- [Katya] Okay. Everybody's
vibing at the party,
but then Xander and Yoly sneak
off to do their own thing.
- Love.
- They look cute together.
- [Mal] Can I step in?
Do you want me to not step in?
- You can do whatever you want.
- Oof.
You can do whatever you want.
This is (beep) weird. Mama, oh god.
- [Trixie] This is the moment
where you actually do need
to make some choices.
- Are we a thing? Are we not a thing?
What's your, what's
the status of you guys?
- [Yoly] So I just want like,
maybe like 5, 10 minutes,
if that's okay?
It's not long.
- Is it a trust thing?
You need me to trust you in this?
- Please?
- Mal is the only adult here.
- I was gonna say like, "Okay."
- Mal's gonna land on her feet with me.
- [Katya] Mama.
- Mal's DMs, when this comes
out. (imitates phone pinging)
- [Yoly] Are we in line
of sight of somebody?
- No.
- Mama, this is gonna be on TV.
- Yeah, let's do this thing.
- Gag.
- Vanessa, by the way, is
snoozin' 'cause Xander has game.
Xander's like, if your woman's
gonna come fake live with me,
she's sticking around.
- Yeah. I'm picking
her up like a six pack,
and I'm not letting go.
- Bowling ball.
- Yeah.
So it's Yoly and Mal's ultimatum day.
- I just want you to know
that I'm still in love
with somebody else.
- [Katya] Damn.
- I mean, that's what you
risk in this experiment.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You know?
- Yeah. There should be no shock here.
- I wrote you something.
- A note? Oh, Christ.
- I choose you, Yoly.
- Damn.
- Oh.
- I knew it was you
three weeks into dating-
- Oh, no.
- I think she's gonna say yes.
She says she has feelings
for someone else.
That doesn't mean that
she won't marry you.
- Three years, three
weeks, what is the data?
- What took you so long?
- I don't know.
- Relationships are not like the movies.
- No.
- In movies, it's like, "We're
in love, and so that's it."
- He picks you up on Hollywood Boulevard.
He pays you $3,000 to
stay for the weekend.
- Uh-huh.
- And then he falls in love with you.
He takes you to the opera.
- Totally.
- That's love.
- But in real life,
every day, you have to choose
to be with each other- - Mmhm.
- and it has to be an easy choice.
- Yeah.
3,000 is a little unrealistic.
You have to be able to settle for 500.
- Mm-hmm.
Tiff and the hottest name
in the world, Mildred.
- Yeah, Mildred.
She just finished her shift
at the bakery in Coney Island
in 1932.
- Just gave her tour at
the Salem Witch Museum,
and she's ready to see if
they're gonna be together.
You know when you get married,
and you wanna change your last name.
I think she should look into-
- Maybe the first one.
- [Trixie] Change the first name.
- Yeah. I don't know.
- Or just be Millie.
- At this point, Deirdre
would be an improvement.
- Girl, anything.
- Yeah.
- Love is a very short word,
like a perfect blend such as the coffee.
- [Katya] Oh my gosh.
- [Tiff] That you make me in the morning.
- Cut to the chase. Are we
going to Denny's or what?
The hyperbole is like
a little heavy handed.
It's like, "You're like the hot towel
that you wrap around my head."
- You know, this makes me feel
like all these dating shows,
we've trashed straight people.
Queer people are just
as capable of cringe.
- Mildred, will you marry me?
- [Trixie] Will you sleep with my dog?
So Sam gave Aussie the ultimatum.
Will they end up together?
I say yeah.
- ("The Princess Bride" impression) Wuv.
- Wuv.
- Tru wuv.
That bwessed awwaingement.
- So there are two species of penguins
that live in the Antarctic,
and when they find their life mate,
they search along the shoreline
and look for the right rock.
- I swear to God, if she
produces a stone from the beach,
I'm gonna scream.
- [Aussie] I give you a heart-shaped.
- [Trixie] Girl.
- Mama.
What the (beep) am I supposed
to do with a (beep) rock?
From the "Egypt Store," bitch.
- From the "Egypt Store" at the mall!
- It was $1 and 99 cents
from the "Egypt Store."
It's supposed to bring you
good luck and nice feelings
during lunch time.
- And I'm supposed to
feel what when I get this?
♪ Ooh baby, I'm worth it ♪
Like, no.
Get that woman a goddamn ring.
- [Katya] Yeah.
- The problem is Aussie is
surrounded by story producers.
- Yes.
- And so instead of a friend
to talk you off the ledge,
the story producer's are like,
"Did you say you wanna give her a rock?"
- "That sounds lovely."
- "Oh, Write that down.
She's gonna love that.
You rolling the cameras?"
- So I choose you.
- No.
- I'm sorry, yes.
Please say no.
I'm sorry. No offense to Aussie.
- My goodness.
- Mama, if she takes that-
- Okay.
- Thank you!
- Aussie.
- Jesus (beep) Christ!
That got really dicey.
- That got dicey. That got dicey.
- That got very dicey for a moment.
I was like, uh.
Vanessa and Xander, this is
where things are gonna get wild,
I think.
- I wish I could give you the world.
I thought that I was gonna be able to.
I thought I was gonna be
able to make everything
that you wanted, all
your dreams come true.
- Sugar bubbles.
- I never realized how
much I needed to grow
until coming here.
- I wanna believe that she is growing.
- I do believe it.
- I really want it, I wanna believe that.
- I do.
- I don't believe it was all
like calculated and nefarious.
Like I really feel like she was clunky.
- Really proud of the person I am.
- Butch presenting girls, they
have the hair of my dreams,
and the outfit of my dreams. - Uh huh.
- And I'm sitting there bald,
and they have a perfect fresh
barber cut. - Beautiful.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I'm beyond bald.
It's a exposed brain, missing skull.
- No scalp.
- If I had that hair and that hairline,
I would be unstoppable.
My life would be different.
- Yeah.
- I wouldn't be here.
- Thank you for our four years together.
They changed me.
- Oh, that's really sweet and sad.
- I don't know who I would be
without those four years with you.
- Are they breaking up?
- Yeah.
Yeah. They're, they're done.
I think it's the right choice for her.
All right, so Xander and Yoly
are now gonna see each other.
It's like, "I did it. I left my husband."
It's like, "Uhhhh."
- Have a beautiful life together.
♪ It's too late, baby ♪
♪ Now, it's too late ♪
♪ She wants her cake and eat it too ♪
- Is she gonna say something?
I don't think Vanessa would've done this.
Vanessa would've just blurted it out.
- Abso (beep) lutely not.
She would never would, she
would not have done this.
- She might have been clunky,
but she would've said it.
- Oh (beep), I just remembered.
I'm engaged.
Fabulous.
- Those blue bails are amazing.
- Fabulous manicure.
- Yoly's manicurist is at
home watching this, going.
And she's watching us watch
this and looking at ours-
- Yeah. She's like, pigs.
Pigs.
- Mal proposed this morning.
I said yes.
- Stop rubbing, stop touching.
- Stop touching!
- Inappropriate. Inappropriate.
Girl, if I was Xander,
though, I'd be like,
"I'm tired of all you, bitches."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'm getting on Tinder.
- Yeah, and I'm gonna
get this pussy blown out.
- Girl, Xandy's in bed with
Sharon Stone next week.
- Yeah, yeah.
Like Cindy Crawford is
literally standing by.
It's Lexi and Rae's ultimatum day.
Let's see what happens.
- [Rae] You make me just
feel safe, protected,
and just loved.
- They're so (beep) cute.
- Yeah.
- Will you marry me?
- [Trixie] Oh god, kneeling
down on a bare knee in a dress?
Get a lil pillow or somethin'.
- [Lexi] Yes.
- She went to Jared's. - Lexi was like.
- Yeah. Okay, so 24 karats, I guess-
- You know I said princess cut.
- Yeah.
- Oh no. You don't have to do that.
- Equality.
- [Lexi] My forever love.
- It's so great to watch
this and not a man in sight.
People need to see this.
People need to see these young,
lovely women being
vulnerable with each other,
being sincere and honest,
and being lesbians.
- It's actually really refreshing
to watch this type of program,
and feel like nobody's
cheating out and playing me
as a viewer.
- This show had it all.
- Rocks.
- Threats.
- Drama.
- Finger blasting.
- Sapphic yearning.
- Love triangles and polygons.
- Lesbians.
- Accusations.
- Wedding rings.
- Pierced nipples.
- And honestly, a lot of growth, I think.
- A lot of sincere growth, learning,
and social and emotional development.
Queer people have never looked this-
- Normal.
- Normal, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Trixie] Like normal.
- Making straight people
look like Frankenstein.
So check out "The Ultimatum:
Queer Love" on Netflix.
- The old tomato.
- I'm gonna go tweet
about this show tonight.
By the way, somebody came into
our dressing room and said,
"Hey, just so you know, the
episode today is Pride Month.
So if you have anything kind of Pride."
And I said, "Do we normally not look gay?"
♪ Pride is the way that we
show that we love one another ♪
Happy Pride, lez.
- Goodbye.
(bright jazzy music)